[Musik]
der astra zeneca impfstoff und sein
akzeptanzproblem virologen betonen dass
auch dieses mittel wirksam vor schweren
verläufen schützt in australien
eskaliert der streit um ein geplantes
mediengesetz facebook blockiert dort auf
seinen seiten alle journalistischen
inhalte und spektakuläre mars-mission
ein raumfahrzeug samt mini helikopter
soll heute abend auf dem roten planeten
landen
und wir alle können live zuschauen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und in allen an diesem
donnerstag schön dass wir dabei sind
christian steuert uns nachher den
sportlern eine bunte mischung genannt
deutschlands impfkampagne steht vor
einem neuen problem generell ist zu
wenig impfstoff da andererseits gibt es
impfstoff der firma astrazeneca der
nicht aufgebraucht wird weil er von
manchen bürgern offenbar nicht
akzeptiert wird
forscher finden das irritierend und
gleichzeitig gibt es orte in deutschland
in denen die sorge wieder steigt und die
jetzt neu durchgreifen anselm stern die
polizei einsam unterwegs in flensburgs
innenstadt ab samstag gilt hier strikte
ausgangssperre in der nacht und neue
strenge kontakt beschränkungen ganz weit
weg ist das von öffnen und lockern die
zahlen steigen hier deutlich der anteil
der britischen mutante liegt
mittlerweile bei 30 prozent
wir haben einen hohen anteil an
mutationen in der stadt und eine jetzt
schon belastete krankenhaus situation
eine belastete situation weiterhin in
einigen regionen im land und die
hoffnung in spritzen kommt nur langsam
ein impfzentrum in bielefeld vor etwa
einer stunde
der wirkstoff von astrazeneca wird hier
gerade verabreicht an pflegekräfte
doch es gibt ganz offenbar auch einige
die diesen impfstoff eben nicht wollen
beispiel sachsen mehr als 2500
impftermine sind in dieser woche noch
frei impfen ja astrazeneca lieber nicht
dieses gefühl scheint es zu geben
ich finde dass die mediziner dann
nochmal der wirkliche aufklärungsarbeit
machen sollten weil der impfstoff besser
ist als sein ruf im moment der
astrazeneca impfstoff zugelassen wurde
er in deutschland nur für unter
65-jährige die wirksamkeit bei beyond
inc pfizer 95 bei moderner sind es 94
prozent astrazeneca etwa 70 und doch so
die einschätzung vieler experten er sei
sehr hilfreich im kampf gegen das virus
meiner meinung nach ist das ein sehr
guter impfstoff der in großen studien
gezeigt dass er zum einen sicher ist und
zum anderen eine sehr gute wirksamkeit
zeit sowohl gegen leichte und moderate
verlaufende infektionen als auch und das
ist das wichtige gegen schwere
infektionen wenn wir schon eine
effektivität und 70 prozent reden heißt
das ja nicht dass 70 prozent der
geimpften nur geschützt sind und 30
prozent sind ungeschützt sondern es
heißt dass jeder geimpfte 71 prozent
reduziertes chance hat zu erkranken und
das ist immer nicht immer noch sehr sehr
ordentlich sagte immunologe kasten watzl
er schlägt heute vor der astrazeneca
schon bekommen hat könnte sich später
mit einem anderen wirkstoff nachimpfen
lassen um die wirksamkeit zu erhöhen
gedankenspiele für die zukunft auf dem
schwierigen langen weg hin zu mehr
normalität in deutschland
impfungen sind ein ausweg aus der
pandemie aber auch tests sollen jetzt
zur wichtigen stütze werden
es gibt mehrere davon der pcr test ist
sozusagen der standard weil er als
zuverlässig gilt andere sind nicht ganz
so genau dafür aber viel unkomplizierter
und viel schneller
diese schnelltests werden schon länger
von geschultem personal eingesetzt und
sollen ab dem ersten märz allen gratis
zur verfügung stehen große hoffnungen
setzen viele in die neuen selbsttests
für zu hause
auch die sollen in den nächsten wochen
zugelassen werden einfach zu handhaben
sind sie mit einem ergebnis in wenigen
minuten christina hansen mit einem
beispiel
es sieht ganz einfach aus und das soll
es auch sein einmal rachen sekret
hochziehen und dann mit dem stäbchen im
mund ausstreichen ab ins röhrchen und
nach etwa zehn minuten ist das ergebnis
da ein schnelltest den man selber machen
kann ohne wie bisher mit geschultem
personal das hamburger medizinprodukte
unternehmen hofft auf eine zulassung des
neuen tests im märz die genauigkeit sei
hoch wenn er korrekt und richtig
angewendet wird dann haben wir eine
zuverlässigkeit von 96 prozent
und ich finde dass es eine hohe rate und
auch mit einer hohen aussagekraft
wichtig ist auch die neuen tests sind
nur eine momentaufnahme
selbst wenn das ergebnis negativ ist
sollten hygieneregeln weiter eingehalten
werden man kann schon infiziert sein hat
aber eine zu geringe noch nicht
nachweisbare virus last tatsächlich sagt
der test etwas über die nächsten wenigen
stunden aus aber auch hier kann es in
gewissen situationen falsch negative
tests geben
doch so schnell wird es nicht genügend
es für jedermann geben ärzte und
kommunen schlagen deshalb vor sie zum
beispiel erst mal an schulen einzusetzen
es gibt den menschen sicherheit und man
entdeckt hin und wieder personen die
infiziert sind ohne etwas zu merken und
das ist genau richtig denn so können wir
infektionsketten erkennen und
unterbrechen falls die zulassung im märz
kommt kann man hier in hamburg sofort
mit der produktion beginnen
bis zu 400.000 es täglich allein für
deutschland ein crooner alarm kommt
heute aus der slowakei dort greift die
britische mutation um sich
möglicherweise eingeschleppt durch
slowaken die in großbritannien ihr geld
verdienen
die lage ist so gravierend dass die
regierung andere eu länder darum bittet
hilfe zu schicken
vor allem die zahl der korona toten ist
extrem hoch
täglich sterben das slowakei mehr als
100 menschen gemessen an der
einwohnerzahl aktuell so viele wie in
keinem anderen land
wolf christian ullrich berichtet
die krematorien in der slowakei sind
überfüllt weil es so viele corona tote
gibt deshalb lagern die leichen in
diesem krematorium inzwischen in
containern auf dem hof ein
bestattungsunternehmen das normalerweise
eine leiche im monat gebracht hat bringt
jetzt drei pro woche
ich habe nie damit gerechnet jemals
container kaufen zu müssen
alarmierend die britische virus mutation
ist in der slowakei schon bei drei
vierteln der korona infektionen
nachgewiesen
auch in dieser klinik spürt man die
zunehmend schweren verläufe sorgen
bereitet jetzt die hohe sterblichkeit
denn in slowakischen krankenhäusern
stück mittlerweile jeder dritte corona
patient an den folgen der krankheit
jetzt kommen auch jüngere patienten mit
schweren krankheitsverläufen um die 20
und 30 jahre alt das war in der ersten
fälle anders der zweite shutdown kam zu
spät sagen ärzte die hohe sterblichkeit
besorgt die menschen
die leute halten sich nicht an die
maßnahmen der regierung
ich weiß dass viele kneipen heimlich auf
haben nagelstudios und schneider nein
auch das ist ein problem
die slowakische regierung verhandelt
jetzt offenbar mit russland über den
impfstoff sputnik und möglichst schnell
viele menschen zu impfen
wir werden politik oder rio strategische
interessen nicht über unser interesse
stellen das leben und die gesundheit
unserer leute zu schützen
die slowakei bietet jetzt die eu und
hilfe fordert zehn ärzte und 25 pflege
an die lage in der slowakei ist ernst
unser nächstes thema hier in der sendung
die nato und afghanistan
das bündnis muss entscheiden ob es bis
mai seine truppen abzieht das hatte der
frühere us präsident donald trump den
radikalislamischen taliban in aussicht
gestellt seit 2003 versucht die nato in
afghanistan frieden und demokratie zu
sichern
zuletzt mit insgesamt noch neun 1600
soldaten 1100 davon stellt deutschland
sie beraten die afghanischen
sicherheitskräfte und bilden sie auch
aus ein gefährlicher einsatz 59 deutsche
kamen bereits ums leben
aber jetzt truppen abziehen das könnte
das fragile land schwer erschüttern
stefan leifert nach erfüllter mission
sieht es in afghanistan noch lange nicht
aus es ist ja 18 des nato-einsatzes doch
immer wieder überziehen radikale
islamisten das land mit terror und
gewalt
dennoch schlossen die usa unter donald
trump letztes jahr ein abkommen mit den
taliban versprachen truppenabzug bis
ende april
dabei könne es nicht bleiben finden die
nato partner
wir haben mit dem einsatz dieser kräfte
über die letzten jahrzehnte erreicht
dass ein friedensprozess in gang
gekommen ist die verhandlungen laufen
aber sie sind noch nicht so
abgeschlossen dass die truppen jetzt
afghanistan verlassen können
das bedeutet aber auch eine veränderte
sicherheitssituation eine erhöhte
bedrohung für die internationalen kräfte
auch für unsere eigenen kräfte beim
treffen der nato-verteidigungsminister
richteten sich deswegen die blicke heute
auf dieses fensterchen der neue
us-verteidigungsminister stellte sich
vor
viele warten dringend auf ein signal aus
washington die afghanistan-mission über
april hinaus zu verlängern
zu diesem zeitpunkt haben wir noch keine
endgültige entscheidung über die zukunft
unserer präsenz in afghanistan getroffen
aber da die deadline erster mai näher
rückt werden wir uns unter den nato
partnern in den nächsten wochen eng
abstimmen und koordinieren wir fühlen
uns unserer unterstützungsmission
verpflichtet die neue us-regierung von
joe biden aber hat um zeit
gebeten um über die mission zu beraten
zeit die die nato-partner aber
eigentlich gar nicht haben auch
deutschland nicht in das bundeswehr
mandat für afghanistan läuft schon ende
märz aus so groß die erleichterung über
den neuen ton aus washington so sehr
werden die ersten wochen mit der beiden
administration für die nato zur
geduldsprobe sagt stefan leifert und wir
bleiben noch im moment in brüssel seit
jahren bemängelt die eu dass deutschland
gegen geltendes recht beim naturschutz
verstößt und weil sich nichts verändert
habe klagt die eu kommission jetzt vor
dem europäischen gerichtshof
es geht vor allem darum lebensräume
seltener und bedrohter tiere und
pflanzen als schutzgebiete auszuweisen
das deutsche umweltministerium sagt das
geht soweit und verweist auch auf
immense kosten
nach der verhaftung eines katalanischen
rappers ist die wut in spanien groß die
zweite nacht in folge kam es bei
protesten in mehreren städten zu
ausschreitungen unter anderem in
barcelona und madrid randalierer bauten
barrikaden auf und griffen polizisten an
allein gestern abend wurden mehr als 50
menschen festgenommen es gab dutzende
verletzte ein gericht hatte den musiker
pablo sl zu neun monaten haft verurteilt
wegen beleidigung der königsfamilie und
verherrlichung von gewalt
die demonstranten kritisieren das als
zensur berlin versucht ja schon länger
härter gegen kriminelle clans
durchzugreifen vor allem gegen
mitglieder der arabisch stämmigen
großfamilie die etwa auch hinter dem
juwelen diebstahl im grünen gewölbe in
dresden stecken sollen heute groß razzia
mit 500 polizisten in mehreren
stadtteilen durchsuchten die wohnungen
geschäfte autos zwei verdächtige wurden
festgenommen und computer beschlagnahmt
hintergrund ist diesmal offenbar eine
fehde zwischen dem arabischen und einem
tschetschenischen klar
beide gruppen konkurrieren etwa im
drogen- und waffenhandel miteinander
zuletzt immer brutaler
so jetzt geht es um etwas ganz
grundsätzlich ist etwas das enorme
folgen hat für die ganze welt
nämlich die frage dürfen internetriesen
wie facebook einfach so journalistische
inhalte verbreiten ohne denen vom werbe
gewinn etwas abzugeben die diese inhalte
produzieren also zeitungsverlage etwa
oder fernsehsender in dieser frage sind
australien und facebook
aneinandergeraten und der streit
eskaliert jetzt facebook hat für
australien sämtliche nachrichten seiten
gesperrt
australiens regierungschef sagt die
digital konzerne sollten nicht denken
sie regierten die welt normen odenthal
der klick auf facebook auch in
australien für viele eine
selbstverständlichkeit doch heute
hielten sich spaß und nutzen den grenzen
alles auf der plattform was von
nachrichten anbietern kommt verschwand
über nacht journalistische inhalte
können weder gepostet noch geteilt
werden die facebook gemeinde hat
plötzlich ein problem
facebook ohne nachrichteninhalte das ist
furchtbar ich nutze facebook jeden tag
eben weil ich da alles abgreifen kann
die ganzen news das trifft nicht jetzt
wirklich auch australiens regierung ist
durchaus geschockt findet aber klare
worte
die sache ist doch so facebook ist ein
wichtiger baustein im digitalen
ökosystem australiens ein wichtiger
wirtschaftsfaktor
wir wollen ja dass sie hier tätig sind
aber wir haben auch klar gesagt dass wir
in australien geschäfte macht sich auch
an die gesetze halten muss das gesetz um
das es geht ist noch in planung es sieht
vor dass plattformen wie facebook oder
google künftig zahlen müssen wenn sie
journalistische inhalte von
medienunternehmen verbreiten
vor allem facebook sagt das sei nicht
umsetzbar und wehrt sich heute drastisch
neben medienseiten wurden allerdings
auch inhalte gesperrt die auskünfte
geben medizinische notfalldienst oder
wetterwarnungen etwa das ist eine
unverschämtheit und nicht akzeptabel
facebook muss das in ordnung bringen und
es darf sich niemals wiederholen
konfrontation mit facebook kooperation
bei google auch dieser gigant hat erst
gemeckert arrangiert sich nun aber und
wird wohl zahlen australien und google
bleiben also befreundet bei facebook ist
das noch nicht klar
und jetzt gehts tief ins all
ein halbes jahr lang hat das nasa
raumfahrzeug persiens gebraucht zum mars
in etwa zweieinhalb stunden soll es dort
landen die letzten meter wird der
fahrenden roboter an nylon schnüren
herabgelassen
das high-tech-gerät so groß ist es im
original hat kameras dabei sensoren
lasertechnik eine drohne und einen
greifarm um so in den nächsten jahren
nach spuren von leben auf dem mars zu
suchen wenn alles klappt sylvia bleßmann
berichtet auf der suche nach spuren von
leben trifft der rover mit fast 20.000
kilometern in der stunde auf die dünne
marsatmosphäre bevor er in nur sieben
heikel minuten in mehreren bremsmanövern
auf dem roten planeten landen soll
wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgehen dass
wir auf dem kraterboden landen dann wäre
eine priorität das vulkanische material
auf dem kraterboden zu untersuchen und
davon auch proben zu nehmen das delta
das für die landung ausgewählt wurde
zeigt eine große biologische vielfalt
der jazz euro karte ist deswegen
besonders interessant weil er mal die
stelle eines haltens es war und in
diesem sind materialien rhein
transportierten von einem fluss die
besonders vielfältig sind vor vier
milliarden jahren könnten auch auf dem
mars optimale bedingungen für leben
geherrscht haben
das wasser gab fanden schon frühere
missionen heraus 8 waren erfolgreich nun
soll porsche wie man's land zu deutsch
beharrlichkeit ausgestattet mit neuen
instrumenten und diversen kameras um
mögliche fingerabdrücke des lebens zu
erkennen daten einer zoom kamera werden
berliner wissenschaftler bearbeiten gibt
also sofort ein umfassendes bild von der
umgebung sehen ja die oberfläche
millimeters gehe also wir sehen sie
wirklich
die eigene hand vor augen ein mini
hubschrauber soll in der extrem dünnen
mars atmosphäre fliegen und am
roboterarm ist ein bohrer befestigt mit
dem erstmals gesteins proben genommen
werden die irgendwann zur erde geschickt
werden sollen um sie auf mögliche spuren
von leben zu untersuchen
erste live bilder vom mars soll es heute
abend gegen 22 uhr geben das heute
journal ist natürlich dabei und wenn sie
noch mehr wissen wollen schauen sie in
unsere app dort gibt es ab 21 30 zdf
heute live mit der übertragung der
landung und den kommentaren von
wissenschaftlerinnen und hier bei uns
auf der erde kommt jetzt christin porto
hat den sport zuerst das schöne fußball
champions league borussia dortmund
selbstbewusst 3 zu 2 1 klasse
auswärtserfolg beim fc sevilla im
achtelfinal-hinspiel dadurch hat der bvb
eine gute ausgangsposition fürs
weiterkommen auch dank seines
überragenden torjägers dortmund und
berlin holland jubeln es ist eine gala
vorstellung des norwegers beim bvb sieg
installieren beim stand von 12 1 holland
mit seinen treffern 17 und 18 13
champions-league-spielen verdiente 3 1
führung zur halbzeit
den patch in der nächsten saison
co-trainer unter marco rose sieht in
halbzeit zwei mal wieder schlechtes
verteidigen die jung 2 3 in der 84 das
aber war es der terminfindung speziell
die champions league ist einfach
speziell wir sind noch nicht weiter
müssen unsere antennen immer ausfahren
immer alles abrufen voraus wir das gilt
auch für die liga am samstag wartet das
revier derby aufsteiger tennis-queen
serena williams usa hat eine weitere
chance verpasst den rekord von 24 grand
slam turnier siegen zu erreichen
in melbourne schied die 39 jährige im
halbfinale aus mit 3 6 und 4 6 gegen die
japanerin naomi osaka ob das nun ihr
endgültiger abschied von den austrian
open war
wissen sie
noch nicht die initialzündung blieb aus
nach dem ersehnten wm medaillen gewinnen
für die deutschen biathleten den pokal
reichte es für franziska preuß und erik
lesser nur zu platz sieben in der single
mixed-staffel am schießstand ging zu
viel daneben gleich zu beginn gerät
deutschland in die defensive startläufer
erik lesser beim stehendanschlag mit
einer strafrunde
deutschland fällt zurück auf rang 16
insgesamt das deutsche duo mit zehn
nachladern franziska preuß bleibt nur
schadensbegrenzung platz sieben am ende
ja medial schade wir haben es einfach
mit überbrachten geht der schnee das mal
einfach beenden kann
der wm titel geht an das französische
duo julia simon und antonio nach silber
für norwegen und bronze gewinnt schweden
und morgen ist ruhetag bei uns nicht du
bist trotzdem lachen und sagen okay
super vielen dank so ins all haben wir
schon geguckt in dieser sendung jetzt
sollte man auch in den himmel gucken
denn da es im moment einiges los mal
etwas geknüppelt mal ganz klar geordnet
die kraniche sind auf dem weg zurück in
die heimat
so ganz vorbei ist der winter zwar noch
nicht aber eines zeigt die rückreise der
kraniche ganz bestimmt der frühling ist
in sicht
und katja ohne versagt uns gleich beim
wetter ob wir morgen schon auf 20 grad
kommen werden der kollege claus kleber
21.45 heute journal mit hoffentlich live
bildern vom mars morgen sind wir wieder
für sie da punkt 7 von uns allen in
allen einen angenehm
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren es
ist das letzte mal für einige tage das
ist ein tief beehrt das ist das
skifahren
es brachte heute in norddeutschland
schon etwas regen jetzt kommt die
kaltfront von frankreich heran
sie hat bereits westdeutschland erreicht
und sie beschäftigt uns auch in der
nacht denn sie zieht weiter ostwärts bis
zum frühen morgen erreichen die
regenwolken oder und neiße aber auch die
schwäbische alb
hinter dem regenband lockern die wolken
auf und mit starken zum teil sogar fast
stürmischem südwestwind sinken die
temperaturen in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen wie hier im taunus oder
im westerwald ist minus 1 grad sonst
bleibt die nacht bei sieben bis null
grad milder und morgen erwarten uns dann
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 6 grad auf
rügen und 15 grad am oberrhein und schon
morgen wird in norddeutschland ein
freundlicher tag einzig in mecklenburg
vorpommern kann es am vormittag bei
westwind noch etwas regnen
in süddeutschland sind die wolken
dichter und zum beispiel an der donau
kann es vielleicht auch den ganzen tag
über trüb bleiben da müssen sie sich vor
allen dingen vormittags noch auf etwas
regen einstellen keinen regen gibt es
dann am samstag da steigen die
temperaturen schon auf acht bis 18 grad
sonntag und montag werden strahlend
sonnig bei höchstwerten von 10 bis 20
grad schönen namen nach